Manny I feel like my anime thing was
like there's three points in my life
where I was I conveyed like very vividly
remember watching anime first was like
Pokemon yeah there occasionally seeing a
Yukio episode of the cards yeah I think
maybe when I got access to like the
Internet I think that's when another one
came because I remember watching like
Yuki I think it was GX right parts three
parts the three parts on YouTube you
know it sounds like an OG anime fan
because they're like oh yeah don't you
hate it when you find an espanol sub of
your your one yeah you okay
so envision it right it's two thousand
right you watch episode 1 part 1 of Yugi
oh yeah okay cool
I'm gonna watch episode 1 part 2 you
click it it's the next recommended video
it's in espanol thank you do you just do
you like keep looking or just give up
and go to the next part
yeah I remember so many times I had to
do that what was then that is when you
like could someone uploads like a full
movie yeah always always like either
like pot six or pot always wanna there's
always one part that was missing yeah
who didn't find it so you just had to
give up and just be like alright I'll
just skip 15 minutes I just hopefully
try and care yeah I think there's 15
minutes of the first Naruto movie that
I've just never seen because I watched
it on TV it's just I don't know what's
happened it might be the best 15 minutes
of like the max upload time is 10
minutes on YouTube right yeah yeah so
that's why I was plugged into three yeah
and yeah and I remember that was like
the one of the biggest day and the third
part would always just be like five
minutes yeah yeah there's the outro help
off of it yeah oh man yeah no that was
like definitely a big phase for me and I
could have been around 13 14 at that
point